This episode is a special crossover from my Python Bytes podcast that I co-host with Brian Okken.
It's got a different vibe than the interview shows here and short topics coming in fast and quick.
If you haven't listened before, I think you're going to enjoy it.
So here are a bunch of excellent Python tips and tools to close out the year.
See you all in the first week of January.
And while I'm talking directly to you, thank you very, very much for taking the time to listen to my shows and support all of my projects.
Cheers.
This is Talk Python to Me, sort of.
Episode 443, recorded December 19th, 2023.
Welcome to Talk Python to Me, a weekly podcast on Python.
This is your host, Michael Kennedy.
Follow me on Mastodon, where I'm@mkennedy.
And if you're new to the channel, I'm Michael Kennedy.